STATEMENT GAME IN THE WAITED AF
BEAT TORONTO TWICE, VEGAS AND
APPEARED OPEN.
BUCKS!
GOOD LUCK, RYAN.
>> I'M SORRY IF I WAS TOO THAT'L
SINCE MOVING TO CE
PULJUJARVI ONE TOUCH BACK TO
DRAISAITL AND PAGE THOMPMP LEFTW
BEBE HERE.
FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO PUT THAT
DOING WORK.
THERE'S NOTHING COACHES LIKE
MORE THAN RIDDLED WITHH RIGHT.
AN EXCELLENT SECOND EFFORT BY
DRAISAITL.
DRAISAITL THIRD SHOT
TO GET THAT SHOT THROUGH.
RIGHT HERE HE TAKES A LITTLE
SPLIT SECOND
AND4:0.
>> DRIVE A YOU KNOW THIS, 25
BACK DEFENSIVELY.
CLEAR.
SHOOTS IT RIGHT BACK IN.  THOMP.
AND NOW BREAKING FREE IS BARRIE
WINS THE
REBOUND, MITTELSTADT.
TTLED BY BOUCHARD.
OKPOSO THAT SHOT AND YOU'RE RIG
FOR JAY.
UP 5-1.